[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant
ma vie était banale ordinaire voire
ennuyeuse mais deux parents
travaillaient tout le temps ils
n'étaient jamais là à la sortie de
l'école j'allais chez une gardienne et
toutes mes vacances scolaires je l'ai
passé au garage automobile de mon
grand-père à la campagne
éloigné du village et livré à moi-même
j'étais toujours seul et je m'ennuyais
terriblement je me souviens avoir posé
un recueil de poésie sur le rebord de ma
fenêtre et j'ai regardé pendant des
heures le vent délicatement tourné les
pages
l'ennui était mon quotidien dans cette
petite ville de province où j'habitais
et de sentir le vent en venir à ma
rencontre comme un ami
cela m'apaisé
à l'école à l'école
à l'école je n'ai jamais vraiment brillé
j'étais toujours à côté en décalage et
je passais le plus clair de mon temps à
regarder à la fenêtre le ciel et les
nuages et c'est donc péniblement que
j'ai obtenu mon baccalauréat après deux
redoublements
si je devais résumer cette période de ma
vie avec les mots du poète je dirais que
mon cœur était froid ma tête était vide
et j'étais triste et je ne savais pas
vraiment pourquoi
issu d'une famille modeste
et pour payer mes études j'étais alors
étudiant en fac de géographie je
travaillais pour une petite entreprise
de nettoyage et de ramonage industriel
j'y effectué quelques livraisons de
matériel
et je me souviens très bien de ce
mercredi matin 19 février 1992
je n'avais pas encore 25 ans
je me suis levé tôt très tôt comme
d'habitude pour pas être en retard pour
les livraisons 5 heures du matin il
faisait froid très froid
j'ai démarré mon véhicule j'ai mis le
chauffage à fond puis je suis allé
gratter mon pare-brise
une fois de retour dans la voiture
j'ai allumé la radio
c'était une chanson de Jacques Brel
je suis sorti de Bordeaux assez
facilement il y avait peu de monde sur
la route et j'ai pris la direction de
Périgueux
je refaisais le point dans ma tête du
matériel à transporter pour ne rien
oublier aspirateur canne de ramonage
lampe torche
j'ai ouvert les yeux
et je me suis réveillé dans une chambre
d'hôpital plusieurs jours plus tard
mes parents et ma petite amie étaient là
la douleur était partout et je ne voyais
dans leurs yeux
que la peur et la peine de la situation
j'avais mal terriblement mal partout mon
corps entier me faisait mal à partir de
là j'ai enchaîné opération sur opération
plus de 20 interventions chirurgicales
je me souviens avoir demandé à mes
parents de me rapporter un walkman
et c'est là que je me suis aperçu que je
n'entendais plus de mon oreille gauche
alors j'ai pleuré mais étrangement il
n'y avait pas de larmes sur mes joues
j'ai voulu serrer très fort mais pas en
contre moi
mais il n'y avait plus qu'une seule main
plus qu'un seul bras
fracture du rocher canal lacrymal coupé
amputation et tout le reste tout le
reste
chaque seconde la douleur chaque jour
l'horreur
la douleur contient la douleur
elle s'enfuit au plus profond puis
jaillit lentement la surface elle tourne
elle danse elle sourit et par politesse
arrache ce qu'il manque
toutes les blessures ne se valent pas
après de longs mois passé sur mon lit
d'hôpital ce fut le temps de la
rééducation
dans un centre spécialisé c'est une
passion période longue et difficile
les matinées sont consacrées à
l'orthopédie
et l'après-midi et le reste de la
journée
je les passe à la fenêtre à regarder le
ciel et les nuages
en me questionnant
mais qui suis-je devenu
puis ce fut l'étape de l'appareillage
la mise en place d'une prothèse d'un
membre artificiel fait prendre
conscience que rien ne sera plus jamais
comme avant c'est la période
indispensable du divorce entre mon corps
et mon esprit et je découvre peu à peu
que je suis devenu une personne
handicapée et que plus rien ne sera
jamais comme avant
il faut apprendre à vivre sans une
partie de soi
je réalise aussi
que mes amis étudiants se sont peu à peu
éloignés
ceux avec qui je passais du temps à la
cafétéria universitaire à étudier
à rire aussi avec la beauté de la
jeunesse
ne sont plus là eux ils continuent ils
poursuivent leur chemin
ils réussissent leurs examens
ils obtiennent même peut-être leur
premier job
c'est alors un sentiment
à la fois d'injustice et d'abandon qui
mettront et moi et moi que vais-je faire
que vais-je faire à présent moi qui n'ai
pas de diplôme pas de projet plus
d'avenir
et le temps a passé presque 4 ans déjà
depuis mon terrible accident
depuis qu'un camion m'a coupé la route
depuis qu'un chauffard
m'a coupé la vie
et je souffre toujours autant toujours
les douleurs du membre fantôme hante mes
jours et mes nuits
c'est dans ces conditions et à bout de
souffle
que j'ai imaginé alors que j'ai circulé
sur le pont d'Aquitaine
en finir avec la vie
c'est une certitude qui transperce le
coeur c'est un carreau de flèche qui dit
la vérité Denis il n'y a pas
d'hésitation à voir c'est ici que le
chemin s'arrête
et au même moment
au même instant
j'ai pensé à tous ceux qui chaque jour
étaient à mes côtés qui m'ont soutenu
durant ces longs mois
d'hospitalisation et de rééducation mes
parents ma famille mes amis et surtout
ma petite amie
celle qui est restée à mes côtés durant
cette terrible épreuve celle qui
a choisi
de continuer son chemin avec moi en
m'épousant alors que j'étais encore sur
mon lit d'hôpital
la force de l'amour de mes proches la
force de l'amour de ma femme
m'a permis
de me rendre compte de l'importance de
la vie et c'est là où tout là-haut en
haut du pont d'Aquitaine que j'ai choisi
en conscience de vivre essayez dans ce
désir de vie que j'ai eu l'irrémédiable
envie de la serrer tout contre moi et de
lui dire que je l'aime et de lui dire
qu'on va regarder et continuer de
regarder ensemble le ciel et les nuages
à la fenêtre
il n'y a rien de plus précieux
que le sentiment d'exister pour
quelqu'un
il n'y a qu'un seul bonheur en ce monde
c'est d'aimer d'être aimé
seule l'amour garde vivant
mais comment faire comment faire pour
rattraper le fil de la vie
étrangement et comme un rendez-vous
inattendu j'avais vu la veille en
reportage sur un service hospitalier qui
prenait en charge les zones les jeunes
adolescents suicidaires
à 28 ans et bien que jeune adulte je
décide de m'y rendre à mon arrivée j'ai
prononcé deux mots
et des mois j'ai immédiatement été pris
en charge par le personnel hospitalier
et c'est depuis ma nouvelle chambre
d'hôpital
en regardant à la fenêtre le ciel et les
nuages que je me suis juré de m'en
sortir
j'ai alors
grâce à mon envie de vivre l'amour de
mes proches les soins prodigués
je suis sorti de cet établissement en
seulement cinq jours
15 jours plus tard je m'étais faim avec
la difficulté qu'on imagine à la prise
de morphine
et j'ai dans la foulée réintégré la
petite entreprise de nettoyage et de
ramonage industriel avec l'émotion
à mon arrivée je découvre
[Musique]
que cette entreprise est au bord du
dépôt de bilan
alors je propose mes services de
commercial pour tenter d'éviter la
liquidation sans expertise ni expérience
dans ce domaine je troque alors mes
chaussons et mon jogging que je portais
depuis presque quatre ans contre un joli
costume et une belle paire de chaussures
pour aller voir les clients et les
nouveaux prospects
les premiers rendez-vous sont très
difficiles
j'ai peur
oui j'ai peur
j'ai honte aussi alors
je cache tant bien que mal mon handicap
c'est que je ne veux pas être choisi par
compassion
je veux être choisi pour moi pour
moi-même pour mes propositions
ma détermination mon enthousiasme
et
mon envie la persévérance
finissent par donner des bons résultats
rapides et concluant une visite une
commande la confiance est là je
développe et dynamise le service
commercial de cette entreprise durant 3
ans
grâce à la bienveillance de cette
société grâce à la confiance des
salariés
j'ai appris un métier j'ai appris à
mieux me connaître et surtout surtout à
me sentir utile
après trois ans de dur labeur j'ai
atteint les limites de transformation de
cette société
et j'ai décidé de la quitter
oui de la quitter
mais avec la promesse de revenir plus
fort pour lui dire merci
c'est donc à l'âge de 32 ans en 1999
que j'ai créé ma première société dans
le domaine du nettoyage industriel mais
sans devenir concurrent
puis j'en ai créé une deuxième puis une
troisième
et ainsi de suite
encouragé par les bons résultats je me
suis engagé plus avant dans le monde
économique
j'ai créé
acheter
restructurer développer et innover
j'ai également avec mon épouse
racheté la petite entreprise de
nettoyage industriel celle qui m'avait
permis de revenir dans le monde du
travail comme une promesse
nous y avons développé l'activité
maintenu les emplois créés des emplois
et préparer l'avenir
en 2008 j'ai été approché par
l'association progrès du management
APM c'est une association
composée de 9000 dirigeantes et
dirigeants francophones répartis dans 38
pays
c'est un lieu unique d'inspiration de
respiration
un lieu pour mieux comprendre le monde
la grande école du questionnement et
pour moi vous l'avez compris
c'est l'école de la seconde chance
et j'ai
l'immense joie le plaisir de vous dire
que
j'ai été élu
président
de cette association mondiale
c'est un moment unique dans la vie d'un
homme
grâce à l'amour
grâce à tous ceux qui m'ont tendu et
donner la main
grâce à la poésie
grâce au vent aussi
celui qui tourne
délicatement les pages de nos vies
et aussi difficile soit elle
j'ai choisi la vie
et chaque jour
je regarde à la fenêtre le ciel et les
nuages
et chaque jour
je m'étonne de tant de beauté
j'ai connu la nuit
j'aime le jour et vous
[Applaudissements]